the nationwide measles outbreak hit an
alarming milestone as the number of
cases hit a 25-year high the CDC said 78
new cases were recorded over the past
week now that brings this year's total
to 704 in 22 states most are in New York
State where health officials have closed
seven schools and they're also issuing
fines to adults who refuse to vaccinate
themselves or their children dr. Tara
Narula shows us the expanding efforts to
stop the spread of this deadly disease
good morning good morning Nora measles
is one of the most contagious diseases
in the world and the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention recommends
everyone be protected while no deaths
have been reported in this year's
outbreak in the u.s. at least 66 people
have been hospitalized with more than
700 cases of measles this year the
disease that public health officials
once said had been eliminated from the
US now shows no sign of slowing down we
certainly expect to see additional
measles cases before these outbreaks are
over dr. nancy miss Aigner is with the
CDC the agency says the majority of
people who have contracted measles are
unvaccinated unvaccinated Americans
traveling internationally can be exposed
to measles and they can bring it back
with them the CDC says 44 people caught
measles this year while traveling in
another country some of whom triggered
outbreaks here in the US in New York
City more than 400 cases have been
confirmed since October mostly in
Orthodox Jewish communities city
officials say some unvaccinated members
of those communities contracted measles
while traveling to Israel one must ask
the obvious question how on earth did
this happen local and state officials in
New York are now pushing the legislature
to repeal exemptions to vaccinations
based on religious beliefs this will
save lives beyond legislation some
scientists say the future of prevention
is using data to create disease
forecasts that could warn people of
potential threats
dr. Sarah del Valle is behind the
project people could open an app every
day and then see what kind of diseases
are circulating in their communities
can see the probability of infection
hopefully that will help them take
preventative measures del VA says we're
still about a decade away from being
able to accurately forecast diseases the
New York Alliance for vaccine rights
which opposes repealing religious
exemptions for immunizations says doing
so violates long-standing rights of
religious practices and bodily autonomy
for those who don't know what age should
children be vaccinated so the first dose
should come between 12 and 15 months the
second dose between 4 and 6 years old
the CDC just said for the summer if
you're going to be traveling abroad even
if you have an infant that's 6 to 11
months you can get one dose at that
point and if they're over 12 months
you're gonna be traveling you can get
two doses separated by about 28 days do
people need to be reminded how dangerous
it is like it can kill you yes and you
know secretary a czar said yesterday
that this suffering is completely
avoidable unfortunately most of us
haven't seen what can be severe
consequences of the measles
one out of four hospitalized one out of
twenty with pneumonia one out of a
thousand can develop encephalitis which
is swelling of the brain that can lead
to permanent brain damage and one or two
out of a thousand can die is there
anyone who legitimately shouldn't get
the vaccine there are certain
individuals so if you're pregnant for
example or if you have some immune
weakened conditions cancers or
immunosuppressed so there are certain
events or even severe life-threatening
allergic reaction to the vaccine that's
why we need this group and herd immunity
yeah that's why this is so threatening
because there are so few people who
can't get it they're always good to have
you here thank you
Thanks